Movies like Batman Begins and Batman versus
Superman: Dawn of Justice are full of scenes
lifted directly from the pages of DC Comics.
But as the DC Extended Universe ramps up towards
the next Batman solo film, which is expected
to hit theaters in 2019, director Matt Reeves
has over 75 years worth of Batman stories
to pick from.
And some of them definitely don't make the
grade.
Here's a look at some Batman moments that
will never be on the big screen.
Messiah of the Crimson Sun
If you ever wished the James Bond flick Moonraker
had starred Batman instead, then boy, do we
have a story for you.
Appearing in Batman Annual #8, "Messiah of
the Crimson Son" involves Ra's al Ghul making
a giant space laser.
But after commandeering a Space Shuttle and
engaging in some zero-gravity karate, Batman
defeated the leader of the League of Assassins
by tractor beaming him into the laser blast.
Considering the days of high camp seem to
in Batman's distant past, it's pretty unlikely
we'll ever see this one on screen.
The Hunchback of the Batcave
"Where does he get those wonderful toys?"
In the movies, the Dark Knight's seemingly
endless arsenal of crimefighting equipment
was either provided by Lucius Fox or made
down in the Batcave by Alfred and Batman himself.
It's a pretty good answer... as long as you
don't think about it too hard.
Why nobody down in WayneTech R&D realizes
they spend an unusual amount of time sewing
up wearable hang-glider capes and bat-shaped
boomerangs is anyone's guess.
But honestly?
It actually makes way more sense than what
we got in the comics.
See, in the comics, all this stuff came courtesy
of a hunchbacked mute mechanical genius who
lived in the Batcave and spent his life building
crap for Batman.
Yep, it's true: this modern day, high tech
Quasimodo was named Harold Allnut, and while
he was essential to keeping the Batcave operation
going, he almost never got any screentime
at all, until he was unceremoniously murdered.
The less said about Allnut, the better.
Trial of the Bat-Witch
Want to know the real reason Batman and Superman
seem to always be at each other's throats?
Well, one unlikely explanation was provided
in the pages of 1969's World's Finest #186,
where the Man of Steel and the Dark Knight
head back in time to find out why real-life
Revolutionary War hero "Mad" Anthony Wayne
looks like Batman.
The answer, of course, is that they're related,
but along the way, Superman claims to be a
traveling actor by announcing that the S on
his chest stands for "Shakespeare" and then
sets about convincing the good people of 1776
that Batman is a witch.
This might seem out of character for Superman,
but there's actually a really good reason
for it: He was possessed by a genie.
Obviously.
Nocturna
Hey, remember the time Batman had a custody
battle with a vampire over who got to raise
Robin?
No?
Well, let us introduce you to Nocturna.
After adopting Jason Todd, who was Robin at
the time, this bloodthirsty arch-criminal
then tried to convince Batman that Robin could
only be raised properly if they got married.
A supernatural rom-com version of Kramer Versus
Kramer with Robin stuck in the middle?
Someone call Katherine Heigl!
A Christmas Story
If you think the story of Christmas begins
with a manger, well, you've clearly never
read Batman: The Brave and the Bold #12, which
features the insane tale of how Christmas
truly came to be.
The story starts with Earth being destroyed
and just gets weirder from there.
By the end of it, Batman and his partner Adam
Strange end up literally rebuilding the universe
from within a reality-altering antimatter
stream, coincidentally made up of glowing
red and green balls of light that twists their
bodies.
Strange ends up being stretched out and aged,
with his rotund, bearded appearance imprinting
on the subconscious mind of the rebuilt universe,
creating the idea of Santa Claus.
And Batman?
Well, Batman is actually his elf helper.
Please make this into a movie!
Professor Gorilla
Batman has so many iconic enemies, from The
Joker, Catwoman and Penguin to Poison Ivy,
Two-Face, and The Riddler, that the movies
just don't seem to have room for some of his
lesser known adversaries.
Which is too bad, because that means we'll
probably never see Professor Gorilla in a
movie.
Originally appearing in the Batman manga by
Jiro Kuwata that ran in Japan's Shonen Ace
magazine in the '60s, Professor Gorilla was…
well, he was exactly what he sounds like:
A gorilla who gained genius-level human intelligence
and then tried to exact revenge on the entire
human race.
Hey, if they're going to keep making Planet
of the Apes films, they might as well put
Batman in one!
Robin Dies At Dawn
If you were looking for a great story that
dealt with the psychological trauma of bring
Batman, you could do a lot worse than to go
back to the 1963 classic "Robin Dies At Dawn."
Arguably the best Batman story of the decade,
"Robin Dies at Dawn" shows a Batman who's
struggling with the paralyzing fear that his
life as a superhero will inevitably lead only
to more death and suffering—specifically
to Robin's death, which would cause Batman
to lose his only family a second time.
Of course, it's also a story that opens with
Batman battling aliens in space and ends with
him fighting crooks while wearing most of
a gorilla costume over his bat costume, so
it has that going for it too.
Unfortunately for modern film fans, some things
are so awesome, they can only exist in the
Silver Age of Comics.
Sorry, Rainbow Batman and Bat-Baby!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!